but about maybe five days ago I realized  I'm coming to Denver to interview the  wrong person I should be interviewing  your mascot we all learned apparently  it's making like 600 000 a year did you  see that report yeah so what makes Rocky  the superior  um NBA mascot  he just gives off a lot of energy makes  the half court shots backwards every  time  um actually at a really good rate  um and yeah yeah he just does a great  job great energy so do you know the man  or woman inside of Rocky uh-huh okay  what's he or she like  us that's confidential really is this  top secret that's how it goes is the  identity not revealed does anyone know  rock